SACRED AND PRESERVED IN THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Sean: CONGRESSMEN, THANK
YOU FOR WHAT YOUR ARE DOING.
WE TURN OUR ATTENTION TO FAME,
CONSTITUTIONAL SCHOLAR HARVARD
LAW PROFESSOR ALLEN DERSHOWITZ
THROWING COLD WATER ON THE
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION SAYING
THAT TRUMP IS RIGHT AND A
SPECIAL COUNSEL SHOULD NEVER
HAVE BEEN APPOINTED IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
SOME IN THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
SHARPEN THEIR ATTACKS AGAINST
THE PROFESSOR AND SUGGESTING
HE IS PREPARING FOR A JOB ON
TRUMP'S LEGAL TEAM.
JOINING TO US RESPOND IS THE
MAN HIMSELF AND AUTHOR OF THE
BOOK "THE CASE AGAINST
D.D.S.: WHY SINGLING OUT
ISRAEL FOR BOYCOTT IS
ANTISEMITIC, ANTI-PEACE."
I AGREE WITH THE TITLE OF THE
BOOK.
AND THE PEOPLE WHO SUPPORT
FARRAKHAN.
GOD BLESS YOU FOR STANDING UP
TO HIM AS I HAVE MY CAREER.
GET IN THE ATTACKS AGAINST YOU
AND WHY YOU THINK THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL NEVER SHOULD HAVE BEEN
APPOINTED.
I AGREE WITH YOU.
>> LOOK, MANY ACADEMICS, MANY
JUDGES DON'T LIKE THE CONCEPT
OF A SPECIAL COUNSEL.
WE HAVE THE ONLY DEMOCRATIC
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD THAT HAS
THAT.
IN OTHER COUNTRIES ORDINARY
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT,
PROSECUTORIAL OFFICIALS
PROSECUTE.
THE PRIME MINISTER OF ISRAEL
IS BEING INVESTIGATED BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF ISRAEL.
BY THE ORDINARY POLICE.
I THINK THEY ARE CRIMINALIZING
POLITICAL DIFFERENCES THERE
BUT THAT IS ANOTHER ISSUE.
WE ARE THE ONLY COUNTRY THAT
HAS A SPECIAL COUNSEL.
WHAT IS WRONG WITH A SPECIAL
COUNSEL, IT COMES IN WITH
TARGETS PAINTED ON THE BACK OF
PEOPLE.
AND THEY HAVE TO COME OUT WITH
CRIMES.
BECAUSE IF THEY DON'T, THEY
HAVE WASTED THE TAXPAYERS
MONEY.
THAT IS DIFFERENT THAN THE
ORDINARY PROSECUTORS.
THAT IS WHY FROM DAY ONE, THE
DAY THAT MUELLER WAS APPOINTED
I OBJECTED TO THIS APPOINTMENT
OF THE SPECIAL COUNSEL.
INSTEAD WE SHOULD HAVE A
NONPARTISAN INVESTIGATING
COMMISSION LOOKING INTO THE
ROLE OF RUSSIA.
WHAT DID RUSSIA TRY TO DO.
HOW CAN WE STOP IT IN THE
FUTURE FROM TRYING TO
INFLUENCE ELECTIONS.
GET THE FACTS OUT.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT THE
TRUTH.
THEY ARE SICK AND TIRED OF THE
REPUBLICAN TRUTH AND THE
DEMOCRAT TRUTH.
WE WANT THE TRUTH.
WE ARE NOT GETTING IT TODAY
FROM THE HYPER PARTISAN
INVESTIGATORS.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU ABOUT THE
CRIMINALIZATION OF THE
POLITICAL DIFFERENCES.
THIS IS NOW A MAJOR PROBLEM IN
THE COUNTRY.
I WILL SAY THIS AND YOU MIGHT
DISAGREE WITH ME.
IN THE COURSE OF ALL OF THIS
WE HAVE LEARNED SOME THINGS
THAT SHOULD TROUBLE EVERYBODY.
NOBODY SEEMS TO CARE THAT
HILLARY RIGGED A PRIMARY AS
DONNA BRAZILLE SAID FOR BERNIE
SANDERS.
NOBODY CARES.
BUT TO SEE COMEY, PAGE AND
PROBABLY LORETTA LYNCH THAT
THEY LITERALLY PUT THE FIXING,
YOU KNOW WHAT 18 USC-793 IS
ABOUT.
YOU KNOW YOU CAN'T MISHANDLE
OR DESTROY CLASSIFIED TOP
SECRET, SPECIAL ACCESS PROGRAM
INFORMATION.
IF I DELETED 33,000 E-MAILS
AND ACID WASH THE HARD DRIVE
AND BUST UP MY DEVICES, AS
GREAT A LAWYER AS YOU ARE, I
DON'T THINK YOU COULD GET ME
OFF.
THEN THE WHOLE ISSUE OF LYING
TO THE FISA JUDGE IN THE FISA
APPLICATION AND NOT INFORMING
JUDGES OF WHAT THEY KNEW.
WHO PAID FOR THAT DOSSIER?
THAT IT WASN'T VERIFIED OR
CORROBORATED.
>> A COMMISSION CAN LOOK INTO
THAT.
IN THE END IF THE NONPARTISAN
COMMISSION POINTS TO CRIME OR
PROBABLE CAUSE FOR SPECIFIC
CRIMES THEN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT CAN INVESTIGATE IT.
YOU HAVE CAREER PEOPLE IN THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
WHAT IS A SPECIAL COUNSEL.
HE COMES IN AND HE IS
TARGETING PEOPLE.
IF HE DOESN'T FIND CRIMES HE
WILL BE REGARDED AS A FAILURE.
PEOPLE SAY WELL, WE HAVE
INDEPENDENT SPECIAL COUNSEL.
WHO IS THE INDEPENDENT SPECIAL
CANCEL?
HE COMES IN AND HE BRINGS THE
ORDINARY PEOPLE IN WITH THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT EXPERIENCE.
MOST OF THEM IN THIS CASE
DEMOCRATS WHICH CREATED AN
IMPRESSION --
>> Sean: ALL OF THEM.
CAN I ASK YOU THIS?
>> YEAH.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW ANDREW
WEISSMAN'S BACKGROUND.
>> I DO.
I HAVE HAD CASES AGAINST HIM.
>> Sean: I HAVE TO TELL YOU,
PROFESSOR, IF YOU LOOK AT TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF THE ANDERSEN
ACCOUNTING EMPLOYEES LOST
THEIR JOB AND HE GOT
OVERTURNED 9-0 IN THE SUPREME
COURT AND FOUR MARYLAND
EXECUTIVE GOES TO JAIL FOR A
YEAR AND THAT WAS OVERTURNED
BY THE FIFTH CIRCUIT.
TWICE EXCORIATED BY THE JUDGES
FOR WITHHOLDING EXCULPATORY
EVIDENCE.
MUELLER WAS EXCORIATED HIMSELF
FOR HIS CONDUCT IN THE MITEY
BULGER CASE AND WITHHOLDING
EVIDENCE.
AND FOUR PEOPLE WENT TO JAIL
FOR MURDER.
WHO DIED IN THE JAIL.
ALL FOUND INNOCENT AND
$100
MILLION AWARDED BY A JUDGE.
I UNDERSTAND WHY MUELLER AND
WEISSMAN SEEM TO BE BEST
FRIENDS.
WITH THAT TRACK RECORD THEY
SHOULDN'T BE INVESTIGATING
ANYBODY.
>> I FOR YEARS ARGUED THAT THE
GUARDIANS NEED GUARDIANS.
WE HAVE TO HOLD ACCOUNTABLE
EVERY LAW ENFORCEMENT PERSON
IN THE COUNTRY.
GENERALLY I HAVE HAD THE
DEMOCRATS AND THE LIBERALS ON
MY SIDE.
OFTEN THE REPUBLICANS AND THE
CONSERVATIVES SAID, NO, WE
TRUST LAW ENFORCEMENT.
NOW EVERYTHING SHIFTED AND THE
REPUBLICANS AND THE
CONSERVATIVES WHO ARE SAYING
WE NEED --
>> Sean: I TRUST LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
>> I UNDERSTAND.
BUT THE TOP RANKING PEOPLE.
>> Sean: TOP BRANCH.
YES, SIR.
>> NOW THE DEMOCRATS ARE
SAYING MY GOD, DON'T YOU DARE
CHALLENGE THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
I'M A CIVIL LIBERTARIAN.
NONPARTISAN CIVIL LIBERTARIAN.
TODAY WHAT I SAY BENEFITED
TRUMP.
YESTERDAY IT BENEFITED THE
CLINTONS.
THE DAY BEFORE THAT IT
BENEFITED BOB MENENDEZ.
I DON'T CARE IF IT HELPS THE
DEMOCRATS OR THE REPUBLICANS.
I ONLY WANT TO SEE CIVIL LIB
LIBERTIES FOLLOWED.
>> I UNDERSTAND.
I THINK THE ISSUE OF WHAT THEY
DID WITH THE FISA ABUSE THESE
ARE CRIMES.
I DO BELIEVE WHAT HAPPENED
WITH THE E-MAIL SERVER IS
CRIMES.
AND I BELIEVE THEY RIGGED AN
INVESTIGATION AND I THINK THE
I. G. REPORT WILL BACK ME UP
ON THAT.
>> WORTH LOOKING INTO.
AND I.G. REPORT SHOULD BE MADE
PUBLIC AND THEY SHOULD WAIVE
RIGHT TO PRIVACY AND DEMAND
I.G. AND THE OFFICE OF